- [Voiceover] So let's see if we can solve
this quadratic equation right over here:
x squared minus two x minus eight
is equal to zero.
And actually, they're cutting
down some trees outside,
so my apologies if you hear
some chopping of trees.
I'll try to ignore it myself.
All right. So back to the problem at hand,
and there's actually several ways
that you could attack this problem.
We could just try to
factor the left-hand side
and go that way, but the
way we're going to tackle it
is by completing the square.
Now what does that mean?
Well that means that I wanna write,
I wanna write the left-hand
side of this equation
into the form
x plus a squared plus b,
and we'll see if we can write
the left-hand in this form
that we can actually solve it
in a pretty straightforward way.
So let's see if we could do that.
Well let's just remind ourselves
how we need to rearrange
the left-hand side
in order to get to this form.
If I were to expand out x plus a squared,
let me do that in a different color.
So if I were to expand
out x plus a squared,
that is x squared plus two a x,
I'll make that plus sign you can see,
plus two a x,
plus a squared,
and of course you still have
that plus b there, plus b.
So let's see if we can
write this in that form.
So, what I'm going to do,
this is what you typically do
when you try to complete the square.
All right. The x squared minus two x.
Now I'm gonna have a little bit of a gap
and I'm gonna have minus eight,
and I have another a little bit of a gap
and I'm gonna say equals zero.
So I just rewrote this equation,
but I gave myself some space
so I can add or subtract some things
that might make it a little bit easier
to get into this form.
So, if we just match our terms,
x squared, x squared,
two a x, negative two x.
So, if this is two a x,
that means that two a is negative two,
two a is equal to negative two
or a is equal to negative one.
Another way to think about it,
your a is going to be half of
your first degree coefficient
or the coefficient on the x term.
So the coefficient of the
x term is a negative two,
half of that is a negative one.
And then we wanna have,
and then we want to have an a squared.
So if a is negative one, a
squared would be plus one.
So let's throw a plus one there.
But like we've done and said before,
we can't just willy-nilly add something
on one side of equation
without adding it to the other
or without subtracting it
again on that same side.
Otherwise, you're fundamentally changing
the truth of the equation.
So if I add one on that side,
I even have to add one on the,
if I add one of the left side,
I even have to add one on the right side
to make the equation still hold true
or I could add one and subtract
one from the left-hand side,
so I'm not really changing the
value of the left-hand side.
All I've done is added one
and subtracted one from
the left-hand side.
Now why did I do this again?
Well now, I've been able,
I haven't changed its value.
I just added and
subtracted the same thing,
but this part of the left-hand side
now matches this pattern right over here,
x squared plus two a x,
where a is negative one,
so it's minus two x,
plus a squared, plus negative one squared
and then this,
this part right over here is the plus b.
So we already know that b
is equal to negative nine.
Negative eight minus one is negative nine,
and so that's going to be
our b right over there.
And so we can rewrite this as,
what I squared off in green,
that's gonna be x plus a squared.
So we could write it as x plus
and I could write a is negative one.
Actually, let me, I could
write it like that first.
x plus a squared or x plus negative one.
Well, let's just x minus one,
so I'm just gonna write it
as x minus negative one squared
and then we have minus nine,
minus nine is equal to zero,
is equal to zero.
And then I can add nine to both side,
so I just have this squared expression
on the left-hand side, so let's do that.
Let me add nine to both sides.
And what I am going to be
left with, so let me just,
on the left-hand side, those cancel out.
That's why added the nine.
I'm just gonna be left with
the x minus one squared.
It's going to be equal to, on this side,
zero plus nine is nine.
So if x minus one, let
me do that in blue color.
So, it's gonna be nine.
And so if x minus one squared is nine,
if I have something
square is equal to nine,
that means that that something
is either going to be
the positive or the negative
square root of nine.
So it's either gonna be
positive or negative three.
So we can say x minus one
is equal to positive three
or x minus one is equal to negative three
and you could see that here.
If x minus one is three,
three squared is nine.
If x minus one is negative three,
negative three squared is nine.
And so here, we can just add one
to both sides of this equation,
add one to both sides of this equation,
and you get x is equal to four
or x is, if we add one to
both sides of this equation,
we get, my digital ink is
acting up, I don't know.
All right. Then we get x is
equal to negative three plus one
is negative two.
So, x could be equal to four
or x could be equal to
negative two, and we're done.
Now, some of you might be saying,
"Well, why did we go through the trouble
"of completing the square?
"I might have been able
to just factor this
"and then solve it that way."
And you could have, actually,
for this particular problem.
Completing the square is very powerful
because you could actually
always apply this,
and in the future, what you will learn
in the quadratic formula
and the quadratic formula
actually comes directly
out of completing the square.
In fact, when you're applying
he quadratic formula,
you're essentially applying the result
of completing the square.
So hopefully you found that fun.